yeah i'm helena schmidt uh yeah and i
will talk a little bit about r and
python and first of all i want to know
who does r at all from the people in the
room
okay it's most of you and who does
python maybe
okay yeah so uh
yeah i'm interested in what did you
already know what from what i was
talking about
but yeah first something about me i'm a
freelance data scientist for about five
years now and uh yeah work mostly with
python and r and also give lectures on
universities
and
my background is yeah i have a phd in
gravitational physics
and i also make a german language
podcast about data science called dart
and limb
and
yeah in this talk i will talk a little
bit on
when to rewrite your code and
yeah some comparison of python and r
and then a lot of examples
for data analysis pipes classes
libraries quoting
and combining best of both worlds
and yeah the first question here is
when to rewrite your code
and uh
yeah one good reason to rewrite your
code is when it's impossible to maintain
the code base and unfortunately that
happens a lot
especially on our projects because most
people that don't the program in r are
not software developers and don't know
how to
[Music]
yeah
get a
code base that is actually maintainable
and i'm also working on projects fixing
that for customers
and
yeah
also if you just want to switch
programming languages for example in
your team you have mostly people who are
working with python and yeah but the
code was already in r or
what i have done in the past mostly was
rewriting matlab to r
and yeah that's also
a possible reason and in one project i
had it was yeah the
research project was done in r and then
it should
the idea was to integrate it into a
larger software
but uh yeah that was
not easy in r because
they already used python and so on then
it was cleaner to go with python there
yeah
when not to rewrite your code uh maybe
when it just takes too long and does not
then not useful
and what also can happen when you
rewrite your code is you will lose some
specialized features that you maybe
totally forgot about
because
yeah the people who wrote it are not
there anymore and
the people who need that feature
don't know that it will get lost and
then you start rewriting and nothing
works anymore and
yeah so make sure you know exactly what
you do
and also writing new code means you will
introduce new bugs
that
may have been already fixed in the past
but
yeah now it's a new programming language
and it's hard to cover everything from
the start
okay now i'm going a bit into
r versus python
yeah r is basically the most specialized
language and data analysis why python is
a
programming language that basically
allows you to do everything
and
yeah the strength of our
especially from my point of view are
it's
far easier to prototype your data
analysis code
with this i mean yeah
when i see a data set and i want to know
what's in this data set it takes only
maybe
five lines of code in r to get a good
overview of what i'm looking at
and in python
that's not that easy
i tried that but yeah i always go back
to arwyn
yeah
looking into data at the first time
so
yeah that means the code is also more
compact at least for
data analysis
and one very neat feature of r are the
pipes
the data analysis pipes
yeah and also something called quoting
which i will also talk about today and
of course
2d plots with ggplot2
and
yeah
do you have already worked with python
and mud bloodlip in the past
uh yeah if you know both then you won't
want to use matplotlib anymore
yeah but the strength of python is yeah
it's a much more structured programming
language so the code that you are
doing is much more consistent
and much more structured
while in
r it's possible to write everything in
one line and
yeah make it impossible to read that's
much harder to do in python it's also
possible in python of course but
it's harder to do
yeah and for example stuff like try
catch is in python much more consistent
with raising different error types and
an
r it's always somehow messy to do that
it's possible
but not that
nice
and i also like really the async await
stuff the asynchronous execution in
python
and in r there are some libraries that
can do that but
it's also not that consistent
okay
yeah the most obvious easy differences
of both programming languages is in r
you don't have scalar values
it's always a vector of data
so if you define a variable
and you put a number in there
then it's always the first
of a vector of numbers and
in python yeah
you have to
do that a different way for example with
numpy arrays
and
yeah then you can also
add
vectors and so on
yeah and the other very obvious
differences r is one of the few
programming languages that actually
start counting on one while most
programming languages start counting on
zero
which does not make much sense in
our days maybe in times of c where you
calculate in an array
the position of the data
it was useful to start at zero
but yeah it's quite confusing
for
people who are learning it
newly
okay
so
why to switch from r to python
especially for example
yeah if you just have more developers
that can work on python that's also true
the other way around
or you may want to have the general
purpose features of python
for example
you want to
create an api server that does some data
analysis
and then the users want to
yeah just asked the server what is the
result and it's easier to do in python
but it's also possible to do in r
yeah and
one other reason could be you have a
very specialized library
that exists only in one programming
language
and
yeah i think in r there are more
specialized libraries for data analysis
but in python you get everything else
okay
that was
the general overview
now go to the examples
and
yeah i think the most basic
libraries that you can use in python
that everybody should know about are
python
a numpy
and an r you can just use base r but
base r has the problem that you may face
some
really nasty
things that have inconsistency in typing
for example if you
do a subset
with the square record notation of a
data frame and then you have suddenly
only one
column you are asking for then you get
only a vector back instead of a data
frame and
to
have
yeah to mitigate that problem there are
libraries that
like the player and
the whole tidy verse is a good
starting point for data analysis
uh libraries
and i think
if someone is using r for data analysis
you should always start looking there
okay
now start with the first
example
yeah who does know what pipes are in
r
okay
yeah pipes basically means you
start with some position of the code
and then you have a pipe for example
this is the new pipe
that was introduced by the latest
version of r4.1
but there were already pipes before that
with a different notation
they that come came through some
libraries
and basically this uh what this does is
it forwards the data to this function
and
yeah here the first parameter that you
don't see is the data parameter that is
filled by the pipe
and then you can do the grouping
for example here and then it is
forwarded to the next function in this
case
the summarize function
and
yeah this function is then called for
each of the groups
and the result is
a data frame
or a table which is a special type of
data frames from the tidy verse without
some of the nasty stuff going
on
and
yeah what this does is basically it
counts the amount of data in here in
each group
and then calculates
yeah some statistics of it
and
for this example i use the palmer
penguins
example data
and yeah pipes don't exist
in
python
but you can at least write your code
like
the
exist
because you can
just concatenate everything with a dot
and then
to make it readable
you can use this
backslash to go then to the next line
and make all the concatenations more
readable
and then you get basically the same
but when you start with some
r code that looks like the upper one
and go to the
lower one which is python
then
you will face one problem and this
problem is
it's not a data frame anymore
but
it's
data frames
below data frames
and yeah for that we can look into the
results the first result is
from r
and the second result is from python and
you can see here
this count
belongs to this variable
and this is one sub data frame
and this is a
another sub data frame
so while in r you just get one complete
data frame as a result when using pandas
it's not always the case so when you
rewrite your code in pandas you have to
make
yeah sure that you know what you're
doing
because the structure is different
okay
yeah and what you can also do with pipes
that is really nice in
r is all the filtering and subsetting
and
so on
but that's all
also possible with pandas but not with
pipes unfortunately
okay
yeah the next thing i want to talk about
is objects and classes
has any one of the people who wrote r
code before ever defined a class
okay
two
persons yeah there is something like
object oriented programming in r
as well
and
because
r is a very old language
that is
yeah highly developed right now
there's not only one possibility to
write classes but
many
and uh
yeah the earliest one were the s3
classes
and s basically it was the
the commercial version of r that existed
before r
and that's why a lot of stuff is called
s stuff
and yeah s
three and s four classes basically were
completely different than what you know
from every other programming language
but
there is
one class system
that is similar to the classes in python
and that's the reference classes
yeah and a reference class
is defined
by the ref set ref class function
and
yeah then has a
couple of fields defined
and
each field can have a specific data type
it does not
must have a
data type but yeah you can define it
and then you can add a list of methods
to the class
and in this example i use a very simple
class called yeah
basically a bank account where you can
withdraw some money from
and
this example i take from the advanced
art book
yeah and
one thing that is very special to
are when you do classes
is this
assignment operator who has seen this
assignment operator before
okay it's more people than
people who have done classes before and
what this does is it looks in
a scope above the current scope if there
is already the variable defined
so
you can then assign a value to a
variable
yeah that is not local anymore
and
yeah this is necessary when you define
classes to use this assignment operator
here
and yeah
then i have some simple
examples
for example yeah creating
an object from the class
it's yeah i think with a new function
it's pretty obvious what's happening
here
just defines the variables it's also
possible to
have a constructor constructor defined
that would be a function called
initialize
and then it can also have different
parameters and just to balance
yeah and
basically it's the same
as in python when you copy that without
the copy function
you're only creating a reference and
when you change it it's basically the
same again so you have to use the copy
function if you want to
really have a copy of the object and not
just a reference to the same object
and yeah then
i'm just showing here that when you
do it on the first
account
it has
with and withdraw everything
then
the balance gets zero
and in the other case it stays a hundred
and the same in python
and for python
yeah
i think most of you know but in python
you don't have the special assignment
operator
you are using the self
and
with safe you can define
object local variables like balance in
this case
and
by python does not have the strict
typing
it's possible to use the type of
annotation so that the users or so
or the developers also see
what types you are expecting here
and the same is also with the withdrawal
function it also uses save
as parameter and then you can just
yeah get the data from it
and
yeah creating
objects is basically easier without the
new but
that's not a big deal
but copying needs the copy
deep copy function
because otherwise you would just create
a reference to it
this is where both programming languages
be behave the same
and
what i also wanted to show you is
both programming languages allowed
documentation strings
so the first string in a function can be
used as the documentation of a function
of a class
that's
yeah very good similarities
yeah the other thing i wanted to talk
about or the next thing
in r you always use this library call
and this is basically the same as
yeah from package import star
and
i think since you most of you are
pythonists
you know why it's bad
yeah because you're polluting your
namespace but it's also possible to not
do that
in
r for example
with this
double colon
it's possible to use a function or
something from a package that does not
get loaded separately
and this is basically
then the same
as
yeah importing
the package in python
and then using the dot
to get go to some functions
for the
package
yeah the next thing i wanted to talk
about is the dot dot dot
feature in r
who has seen this before
and who knows what it does
okay yeah the dot dot
you see it
in the documentation a lot and basically
what this means is you can use
every argument that is not defined here
and put a lot of arguments that were not
defined into the function
and then you can do stuff with it
for example in this example i just
create a list
from the dot dot
and the dot dot dot is filled then with
everything that comes from this
so i can put for example
two arguments to the function the one
and b and one is um
yeah
argument and b is a keyword argument
which are the corresponding names in
python
so the same in python would look like
star arcs and star star
quarks
yeah this these names are arbitrary but
in most examples you will see arcs and
quarks for this
yeah and this is basically then the same
as you think dot dot dot r
as you can also see here
so but i have to create the list
to really
use those arguments because without this
list creation in r i can only bypass it
to the next function and that
may be what i want to do but not always
and then yeah
you have the numeric arguments and then
the keyword arguments also in the list
and in python yeah it's a tuple
respectively a
dictionary
okay
that's this feature
and
one other important feature that
r
has
and python doesn't is this
is called quoting
or non-standard evaluation
and basically what this does is
yeah you can
say to our yeah
don't execute this code
and
since r uses a lot of lazy evaluation of
the code
you can do that also afterwards for
example
and you define this function
with the argument x
and then use a substitute function you
say to r yeah substitute x by
the quoted version of x
then you can
yeah basically say when i
put 10 plus 10 to the function
prevent 10 plus 10 to be executed
and
the argument becomes a call argument
instead of
yeah the already calculated result that
you are maybe used to in python
and
[Music]
yeah this is one part in most cases i
already have shown you this in
the examples before
this is
exactly the reason why
you can use
the species and
the column names without
putting in
them into strings here
because r then knows exactly yeah okay
i don't execute the code i don't know
this variable name but yeah the function
then we use for that in the data
while in python the solution is most of
the time just using strings
and that's most of the cases the way to
go
but if you are using
this a lot
then maybe not
one example
yeah
that i have here for example is
i can call this function with this
y
argument and y is not
defined at all
it's not in some data it's not defined
anywhere
but when you use substitute the
code does not break
and then you can test if this is
actually defined in the code
yeah but also you can do it just with
using references in python and names
yeah
but
if you are using this extensively in
r then i don't know any
good way to do it
and as i said it's
used all the time for example when
just doing a simple plot
you can
put
the column names in here
and then calculate it for example here
millimeter to
centimeter and decimeter
conversion just in the plot code
and then you get a
yeah
plot with different
units
and you don't have to do it
in the data but only when you're
plotting
yeah but i'm
not exactly sure how to do it in python
so i cannot show you that
but this is a simple example that should
be easy to
deal with
but i think there could be some
obstacles if you're using this a lot
okay
but if you need this sometimes and not
all the time and you want to work in
r or python most of the time
you can also combine the best of both
worlds
and this means
you can just execute
python
in r
and then converting the data
for example
in rstudio when you're working with
rstudio which is one of the major ides
in our development
you can just
make yeah
a block with python code in it and then
you can use this r dot
notation in python
to get the data from r
and this also works the other way around
so this shows
yeah the first line of the penguins data
in python code when reading the data
from r
and the same the other way around
is this
r code where you can see
yeah with the pi dollar you can get data
from the python code
and
yeah if you try it in our studio and you
don't have the correct package loaded it
will tell you that and install it for
you and
you don't have to think about anything
to use it
yeah it's called reticulate
and it's also possible to do it the
other way around
so when you're working for example with
python in a jupyter notebook
you can
just yeah use
the rpi2
package
and there you can load the r objects
and import some
yeah package from r
and then run r code from python
and yeah the same from r
would be this you can also use the
import function
in r
to load for example the daytime package
get the
utc now
but since i also want to talk about
obstacles
this is
basically wrong
it
uh converts the time zone twice
and uh assumes basically we are
currently in utc plus four instead of
plus two
so when i last
executed the r markdown file
it was not seven in the morning
also not in utc
and you can also see this
converts also to the correct
our
data types
but it's python code in r
yeah
that's
all i wanted
to show you
uh yeah i had some references for
example the advanced r book and the
prima penguins
and you can contact me on twitter or
github
or just write me an email
are there any
[Applause]
questions so thank you so if anybody
have a question i can hand out the
microphones because i didn't have
questions now on the
on slido
yeah
hey uh thank you for the talk did you
ever encounter any project that tried to
combine r and python like in the
manners you showed on the last slides
like okay importing python libraries or
functions
um yeah anything in real life or is it
just theoretically possible to combine
these two
uh the method i showed you in the last
slides did not encounter i don't not
encounter those in projects but what i
encounter was
that
you can use r kernel from
jupiter
and then
yeah
run them through some other code that
does the api stuff and so on and that i
already encountered in some projects
any other questions
yeah
hi thanks for the talk i my question is
have you
do you have any suggestions for
transitioning shiny apps
to python
yeah shiny is most
of the time gg plot in the background
i won't do that i really
yeah i think there's some clone of gg
plot for python
but i never got one for that
but yeah it's really easy to just write
a
server code with flask in python
and when you are using a matplotlib for
example you have to make sure
really using objects
because math.lib with all the examples
that you encounter
in documentation and so on you are
working on a global state
and when you have for example two
parallel
uh
yeah
api calls that run in parallel they will
both write into this global state
and then you will get a mixed up plot as
a result
but
it's possible to use
mudbloodlip as a really object focused
tool
but yeah then the functions are
called differently than in most
tutorials so it's nasty but it's
possible
i already did that
hi thanks for the talk so i have a
question about what's your experience or
maybe suggestion when for example
there's a specific library that i would
like to use for example in production
and it's written in r and my system is
in python like is it worth
kind of translating the code or maybe
try something like
docker to try to make that work as well
yeah it depends for example what i
showed last uh
you can just use that library from r or
from python
with this uh yeah reticulate package and
r or the
r pi 2 package in python
but this does not work in some cases
where the data is transformed
differently differently
and it could break
and if it breaks the easiest way
yeah either
you can use jupiter
jupiter kernels that you can execute
then you don't need docker
but
if that also does not work very well you
can of course use the just
yeah docker put the data in
and get the results from the other
programming language
thanks
is there any other questions
so i might have one then because i'm
curious as well
regarding is more about the packaging
how difficult disease to package r i
mean because i don't know any things in
r so our difficulties is to package it
compared to any like simple python
package
and second question then is like
when you want to have you know c
extension or sight on fins you can do
that in in python can you do something
similar in r or
yeah it's really easy to package things
in r because there is the dev tools
package and then it
yeah you can execute one function that
just creates the folder structure and
then you can put your code in
and
you don't have to think about it much
and there's also the rc plus plus
package
to uh yeah allow you to use just the
plus plus code and from there you can
use everything that is in c also in
python
and it also helps you with converting
the data types
okay
so we can thanks elena against
[Applause]